so I was just uploading my most recent
podcast with social media star Leah
rudic and she has dropped three social
media tips I have never heard before
really gave A New Perspective to social
media to make it more fun and enjoyable
and sustainable is the whole point of
this video sustainability so the first
one she said was to just start I think a
lot of the times I'll get on YouTube and
social media and look at all the gurus
and be like oh well I got to post 15
posts on 15 platforms every single day
was a really bad Gary ve impression
basically what she said is like just
start knowing it's not going to be good
at first now in her defense she blew up
in two years but she tried a lot of
different things in that time that got
her to the point to where she found a
few characters that really clicked and
they were able to help her sell tickets
out on the road and release her most
recent comic special available Linked In
the description of this fun video my
alarm just went off because I am
currently roasting some chicken so I
will be right
back okay it still needed a few more
minutes so the second thing she said I
think I finished my first point but
we're just trying to get these in and
out here the second thing she said was
do you boo I think a lot of the time
something I've been guilty of is trying
to replicate what works for other people
and she candidly admits that although
she's been able to now create consistent
viral content early on she was trying to
do what was working for everyone else
she was trying to follow Trends she was
trying to oh how many hashtags does this
video need or oh this is a popular topic
let me quote trenck that but long story
short find your unique voice find what
you find interesting and the main reason
for this is authenticity people can
literally tell on social media when
you're being inauthentic when you're
very scripted and rigid and you're
trying to overthink or overproduce your
bad content at the end of the day you
can shoot in 4k but if it's not
interesting or it's just a water down
version of something else already
working you may get a little
shortterm pop from it but it's not going
to be sustainable do you boot be
authentic on stage whatever most
interests you whatever is most organic
to you is what's going to be able to be
organically po posted over and over and
over again which is the name of the game
which leads us to the third name of the
game which is have fun now I know that
sounds obvious on the surface but Leah
admits that over 70% of her ideas end up
nowhere there's a lot of times I asked
her in depth about her writing process
and how she comes up with such great
ideas that do go viral and she admits a
lot of the time it's her just sitting
sitting there just looking at the wall
just trying to think about what should
she do oh here's an idea let me follow
that for a little while creating content
is a lot of work she comes up with ideas
she scripts them she records them she
edits them she uploads them to all the
platforms like it is a lot of work so
you want to make sure whatever you're
creating you are having fun with and I
think that's what social media is
missing right now is
that fun aspect that energy exchange
between people I think a lot of right
now we're all just like posting like
what can I get from this platform what
can I get from this person liking what
can I get from let me get a follower let
me get a follower hey man let me get a
follow let me hold something fam but no
cap if you just post something you enjoy
that you're having fun doing putting
that energy into your content it will
translate through the screen which was
the whole goal of this video I've
honestly inter interviewed over 400
comics on this YouTube channel I've also
done video essays and comedy special
breakdowns and really
overthought how do I make this content
the best it could be and then this video
I was like bro I
mean I just did a dope interview with a
dope comedian who dropped a lot of dope
insights that I haven't really heard
before that I think other people would
enjoy so if you like these you can watch
the full interview right here and
subscribe if you enjoyed this and we'll
maybe do more of these
breakdowns it's pretty basic obvious
advice but it's just just put it just
put it out just like move I think just
being comfortable with like not being
amazing right away oh the
chicken